[Music]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have is what
brings us here today at Alabama Comicon
yeah we are here to join these two
beloved devil boner and hyper fan where
is she anyway
oh she want to wait for the video to
start so she could walk down the aisle
okay Bob hunter
[Music]
she looks beautiful yes then walk down
the aisle with her father she chose to
walk with that glowy effect
[Music]
here to witness this union is penny
devil boners best man yeah but not the
shot oh and nostalgia critic Piper
friend girls I think the term were going
with his Butler of honor okay cool
whatevs
the Rings please
our daily committed have decided to
write their own vows I want you I want
you then by the power invested in me by
me I now pronounce you psycho husband
and stalker wife you may know kit well
that works too Hey see how this is a
convention and we're already clearly
liquored up let's just have the
reception here peppermint schnapps for
all
Oh times Messier - so how does it feel
to officially be hyper boner as excited
as the name sounds Oh wonderful of you
excuses we're gonna see if the flowers
are smokable I'll admit I didn't think
hyper boner was a good idea but after
seeing all the joy displayed it's clear
that hyper boner is going to last a long
time ain't it the truth
nice suit back at you Oh doesn't a hyper
boner look up incredibly whenever
anybody sees you they'll say you can't
keep hyper boner down for years to come
yeah it's about what we predicted you
know sometimes a name can spark a lot of
possibilities there's been so many films
and shows that suggest something is
going to be amazing just based on the
title alone some of them work some of
them don't and then there's movies that
thought the name first and clearly wrote
around it you know where I'm going with
this
[Music]
chipwrecked is the third in the question
in humanity film series based on alvin
and the chipmunks and if you can believe
it it's not the last by this point it's
made clear that a bad pun is literally
enough to throw millions of dollars into
a film shoot exploiting kids inability
to say no to shit it's just as phoned-in
and tired as you would think but why
generalize when we can go into more
detail well I can think of a lot of
reasons but if I'm allowed to leave a
wedding early so I don't have to listen
to any more hyper boner jokes I guess I
can suffer for you
this is shipwrecked the film knows
parents want to go home as quickly as
possible so jumps right into it with
barely an opening at all which is
fitting because this is barely a movie
at all no Jason Lee you can't pack up
and leave the franchise that easily whoa
where have I been trying to board the
ship it's not easy looking older and
sadder with every passing film something
going on a family vacation and no that's
all the set up we get we don't even know
where they're sailing to but I do know
the next four song in there bullshit
soundtrack
[Music]
I'm glad to know there's great security
on the ship microphone attention
attention the moon landing was fake and
earth is flat yeah but you didn't know
you were rooting for that kind of movie
to make punchlines work Wow
gotta love how invested some of those
families look was this take eight
they're pretending they're excited about
a table with nothing on it
no wonder they had to switch out these
kids mid at it there I did the thing now
let me contemplate my life's mistakes so
Dave tries to set more rules for his
rodent ruffians not even five minutes in
and we're on song three why don't you
just implant the soundtrack into my
brain like Dark City you know you would
if you legally toyed what the hell are
you wearing towels you literally showed
up in the film's naked you don't even
wear pants I mean none of this where are
you going oh no no no no dad we are old
enough to make our own decisions you
know it's time to think this whole film
exists just so everybody could go on a
cruise what are we shooting today the
bed floor let some CG artists who want
to work for Pixar do the rest casino
time
[Music]
shitty song for by the way you will hate
this soundtrack more than frozen my
friends foot or her busted tired little
dance moves oh one of those common
occurrences where the entire casino goes
quiet and three grown women feel they
have to show up squirrels have you ever
casino do those squirrels could be
lighting fires and nobody would look up
from their hand I feel like I'm watching
a dance-off between Happy Meal toys and
the Powerpuff whores what the hell is
going on right now we call that move the
I'm a little teapot seizure but there
glitch in the matrix who choreographed
that one of the Rhapsody Street kids
[Music]
come on we'll do better in our dance-off
against the Muppet Babies Dave meanwhile
has a talk with the ship's mascot an ex
five nights at Freddy's character when
he reveals himself to be a familiar face
oh my god I don't care that you called
filming does the most unpleasant
experience of your career that just
means you understand the pain I'm
sitting through what are you doing here
I'm working Dave it's the same
conversation that David cross fan has
when he sees him in one of these films
what are you doing here I'm working
not too many record labels are
interested in hiring the guy who blew it
with the Chipmunks blew it with the
Chipettes and passed on Justin Bieber to
be fair it is hard to tell the
difference between the Chipmunks and
Justin Bieber Bieber's a little shorter
I'll be watching like a hawk
I live David crush you're like Jesus
giving Ben her water you don't fix
everything but I'm glad you're here Dave
sees they let Fyodor alone to watch
Cookie Monster's meth meltdown as he
notices everyone has vanished Alvin
Simon girls I forgot your names like the
rest of the audience so I just call you
girl Alvin girl Simon and girl Theodore
he finds them in the casino and warns
them that they don't behave he won't
take them to win their possible
international Music Award I can tell
you're just as concerned about that as I
am you're all lucky Captain Corelli's
allowed you one more activity
shuffleboard yeah by now Jason Lee is
realizing this isn't gonna be as easy as
the last film where he literally slept
through his performance this time he's
got to suffer with the rest of them hey
hey wake up you cheater
it's at times like this I wish this was
the bow from speed two's a will to folk
em and throw them into the ocean I can
dream but I always had to wake up in the
world where this exists Alvin goes
parasailing on a kite and of course gets
caught in the wind as well as Dave's
chair the original tagline for the film
it's okay this happens a lot I'm
actually a terrible parent called DCFS
David Cross gets forcibly roped in again
a fitting metaphor as they fall into the
water far away from where the Chipmunks
fell into the water
your ass is honest show some dignity
meanwhile Jason Lee and David Cross are
clearly not in the same water they were
a second ago and they discover an island
that the Chipmunks discover as well the
chip once built a fire and yeah we're a
man short of theatrical runtime go ahead
[Music]
it's funny because we hate everything
now
[Music]
you
[Applause]
so lien crusts make it to the island and
as you imagine they don't get along
cross repeats what he told the producers
of this film every day I'm not one of
your tip mugs that you just boss around
and stuff into a cage whenever you feel
like it
meanwhile the chip mites make sure their
auto-tuning still works weird theory
what if they're the deformed
time-traveling rat that's from lost and
they're just trying to make their way
back home it's a weak theory I know by
much rather work on Dad's don't work on
watching this crazy suggestion guys we
eat Theodore you know you eat us if we
don't eat him first they find a little
bit of food in the jungle and everybody
chases after it Oh
[Music]
Gollum says that it's fine because
Gollum says that he says that but they
come across an unexpected individual a
woman named Zoey
played by Jenny slate I was on my way to
be funny I'm Bob's Burgers but I guess I
can stop and be unfunny here whatever
you're a food source kindly get on the
fire so it looks like she's trapped on
the island too
for how long you might ask week week and
a half maybe she also fell from the
cruise ship eight or nine years you know
what was I expecting logic joy charm out
of a chipmunk movie of course she's been
there for nine years
who else would her skin barely be dirty
her hair permed her clothes ballast and
she's crazy enough to talk to sports
balls like castaway yes smart enough to
make a house even Georgia the jungle
will called bullshit I did I expect more
no I get less somehow Simon is bit by a
spider and starts to go through a
strange transformation in his sleep
[Music]
knowing this movie he'll probably wake
up like this fine actually believe it or
not the real change he goes through is
even stranger he wakes up as a Rambo
type adventurer who is also a smooth
romantic and has a French accent would
you care to join me on my adventure yeah
I don't get it what the hell is this
referencing hinting at or anything he's
like this through a good chunk of the
movie like we're supposed to understand
what this is satirizing and I'll just be
honest I have no idea what's supposed to
be funny about it
it's like someone went to a random word
generator and was like I'm literally
gonna let you write Simon's character
just give me three random words
Rambo French horny okay those last two
are the same thing but it's shipwrecked
what do I care as you'd imagine the
girls particularly Jeanette find Simon's
new personality irresistible what I
wanted to do since the moment I laid my
eyes on folder on you deflower you know
good I got it from his wife see guys
pick a book
after dancing the hormones away they
come across a beautiful waterfall it
means that joke will really be dated as
soon as it's used into chipmunk movie
Simon dives into the water and discovers
a room full of gold but he's down there
for so long that everyone starts to
worry about him ah attention averted
continue with your tedium maybe this
might be a right to lucky guy
were there any other jewels or gems or I
had already been gone for mazanik
factory long well know what I think he
was asking what the joke for that scene
was did anybody catch it no don't rewind
it I'm fine leaving it a mystery
meanwhile Jason Lee and David Cross
continued to wander through the jungle
and wait let me guess he's trying to
prove how much he loves his kids and his
kids are trying to learn responsibility
show me a cook that's always it it's the
only thing guaranteed in these movies
outside of out of nowhere shitty supply
he founded the rest of the treasure is
mine
[Laughter]
so Zoe's a villain now I've had bigger
twist with my lemon in my rum and coke
with no lemon but hell let's just go
with it when Zoe find she can't reach
the gold room herself she decides to
kidnap one of the Chipmunks to help her
okay for this movie that was really
weird I didn't think there was a way to
make an evil basketball version of my
neighbor totoro
surprisingly ahem crossed my mind that
much but you accomplished it movie
here's your trophy the Chipmunks finally
and cross and build a wrap together to
get off the island but oh no not only do
they realize Jeanette is missing but a
volcano is about to blow and the
professor made a lie detector out of
coconuts I think this is one of those
situations where even if you fix it it
doesn't fix it on top of that Simon is
hit on the head with a golf ball
snapping him out of his delusion the
movie seems to have forgotten it was a
spider bite that caused him to x-range
and not a bump on the head but the
credits are so close let's not slow
things down I'm coming with you
absolutely not it's too dangerous
[Music]
pay him all the time absolutely nothing
is being learned from this honestly
obeying him would be the strange thing
342 million dollar crossing movie Zoey
forces Jeanette to get the gold as
Jeanette reminds us that even as jukebox
musicals go this one's still especially
bad
[Music]
always in there anyone to hear my other
person singing sped up to sound like my
voice the others come across Zoe though
as they try to rescue Janet
[Music]
take this knife that magically changes
size in midair babe I know you know why
don't the three of us sit down for a
minute and really think about what our
agents did to us like really Mull it
over at the very least we have David
cross the cynicism to get us through all
this a penis fin there I wish I could
get back all those years I spent
plotting my revenge no no don't you ruin
cross movie hate anger regret and what
consumed me and they're consuming you
don't you ruin it movie don't you Rosie
what's the only funny thing in any of
these it's not too late to do the right
thing or not again I'm good either way
so I don't want to sway you okay I was
funny that was I wanted to put up with
that you are across I am willing to bear
they escaped the last minute color
correction and that scathing smoke
somehow as they all sit down to think
about what they've been through okay
people are way too forgiving of
attempted murder in these films can't
there be like a something oh yes Alvin
like lesson you were trying to teach me
learn Jerry low life lesson you're
trying to teach me learned things too
well
pass keep flying
they of course make it in time for the
Music Awards we never actually figure
out if they win anything
I'm just assuming no shift give cross as
your agent and the credits mercifully he
roll so that was chipped wrecked it was
tough to get through and when you really
think of it we're still going we're
still go I'm sorry sir we're gonna have
to get Chuck though gonna charge me 25
bucks a pack bullshit man we have a deal
you roll the credits we get to go what
the hell's love to show that shit monks
eating schwarmann sir please return to
your seat we're about to take off but he
it as an actress from an actual good CGI
film eyehole superiority that almost
killed my stuntman Oh
and that finally is chipwrecked and I
had to give him credit it lived up to
what it promised it felt like I was
watching people thrown off a ship and
slowly died it's such a rush to cash in
that's not even disguising how much of a
rushed cash and it is it has nothing for
a dolt what it has four kids you could
get off of a children's screensaver
it's totally devoid of charm that is
again for David Cross yeah I have to
give credit I always enjoy seeing him in
these films despite him clearly being
above this material he's the only one
who can get a smile out of me with some
of these awful lines aside from that
though it's best to leave this piece of
driftwood washed up on shore it just
goes to show you can't really turn out
anything of value when your base is
nothing but a bad pun thank you thank
you I can see hyper boner lasting a long
time too I'm really having second
thoughts about this hyper boner thing
big time yeah I love your name but I
just don't think that it works for me
yeah wait a minute
whatever your is with him the last name
that changed what are you saying honey
bottoms I'm saying that from this day on
I shall be known as devil bad girl don't
do that oh thank god you know I really
didn't want to let's just kind of do it
to make you happy let's just keep our
last names whatever keeps you just the
way you are is fine by me come on let's
consummate our marriage the way that
most newlyweds do you mean by passing
out because there's suck the life out of
us oh you got it
[Music]
[Applause]
hate anger regret those aren't just
members of a girl group on one side
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout on this week we are doing next for
autism next for autism transforms the
national landscape of services for
people with autism by strategically
designing launching and supporting
innovative programs they believe that
individuals with autism have the
potential to live fulfilling productive
lives when supported by excellent
services and connected to their
communities while many organizations
engage in efficacy or fun scientific
research next for autism addresses the
needs of people with autism and their
families across the country right now
they create and support exceptional
educational clinical and vocational
programs all cutting edge all with an
eye towards effecting fundamental shifts
in current approaches to autism services
if you look at their site in their
YouTube page you can not only see all
the good that they do but the number of
celebrities and entertainers they have
also gotten behind it check it out and
see how you can create a new and
improved future for so many
you